[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another the week in 60
minutes from spectator tv recorded in
london this week on thursday
november the 5th now on this week's show
we will naturally be kicking off with
the u.s election still unresolved
but maybe getting there uh we'll bring
you the latest and what it all means the
big news back in britain
of course is lockdown number two has
begun
we're going to look at why what it means
what the data was that got the
government
uh to force this on us we're going to
have a leading statistician in the
country
david spieger-halter to talk us through
the figures fraser two will
have his famous nelson charts as well
terrorism has returned to europe both in
france in a big way
and in austria too we're looking at
what this means for a clash of
civilizations with a turkish
journalist and the rise of erdogan and
the muslim brotherhood in that country
in a country that in
recent years most of the 20th century
was heading in a secular
direction no longer now if you subscribe
to the spectator
uh this week in our u.s election so you
get 10 weeks
of the magazine in print and online for
the price of one
i mean 10 for the price of one even the
politicians in america didn't offer the
voters that
not only that you get a commemorative
spectator mug
just go to spectator dot co dot u k
slash
president to subscribe now it's only
linked
to the us election we'd like to begin
with a special thanks
to charles stanley for supporting this
episode of the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms and one
of the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange
the american elections the result is
still undetermined uh but
perhaps by the time you see this mr
biden the democratic challenger
will have won enough electoral college
votes the magic number is 270
to tip it over the line and into the
democratic camp
that is what looks like what's been
happening over the past 12
to 15 hours it's been going mr biden's
way
as the later votes come in and by later
i mean later in terms of being counted
they actually came in early
as mail in votes or as
in person voting beforehand but in a
number of
key states pennsylvania being won they
don't actually start counting these
votes
until the polls closed late on
the night of the third don't ask me why
part of the problem is
the constitution in america gives the
state
most specifically the state legislatures
the right to decide how these elections
take place so you've almost got 50
different sets of rules
which is why it's taking uh so long
and even if by the time you see this mr
biden has
moved into the lead and got the 270 that
would suggest he is the next president
there will
almost certainly be recounts in
wisconsin
and in georgia because the victory for
mr biden there if that's what it is
is so slight so it's a changing picture
but there are themes trends developments
lessons to be learned that we can talk
about and i'm going to do that
with james versailles the spectator's
political editor who has a deep
knowledge
of american politics and kate andrews
the spectator's economic correspondent
she is from the colonies so she's able
to tell us
all about that too james give us your
take so far
so i think what we're seeing so far is
that joe biden is likely to become
president but this election hasn't been
the kind of blue wave that many were
expecting it looks like the senate
will stay under republican control and
the house will be democrat but the
democrats margin there has not
increased and i think lots of people on
the democratic side
hoped that this would be a moment when
trumpism was repudiated
wholesale and the democrats won
control of the whole of the washington
system and could push through big change
i now don't think that is likely to
happen i think the republican
senate will act as a check on president
biden i think he will be but
much more back to kind of washington
deal making which
you know biden having been in dc for a
very long time will be adept at
but it'll be that kind of presidency
rather than a kind of
bold radical agenda kate why did it
prove to be such a struggle for joe
biden and the democrats
i think the democrats had a lot of
missteps along the way
joe biden was not out properly
campaigning in the weeks leading up
to the election in the way that you
would expect a presidential
candidate to do so to be out meeting
people and actually if you compare the
rallies that donald trump was having to
those joe biden was having
sometimes networks would put them up on
tv to compare and contrast them
the presidents were dangerous but
ironically they were also a return to
normality
they represented normal and something
more exciting going in
to the next year you know big crowds of
people cheering waving american flags it
was what people
uh were used to what people missed and
then you had joe biden
with very small numbers of people
standing in these circles that were
marked by tape dressed in ppe
listening to a man with a mask on and it
was far
less appealing and and now the democrats
have a big problem that donald trump is
going to try to make
they're moving into the white house in
many ways is as difficult as the
democrats did
for donald trump i don't mean to
directly compare it i think the
president's tweets
about how democracy was being undermined
was actually undermining democracy they
were deeply irresponsible
but let's not forget the the russia
report the democrats saying for years
that donald trump had
colluded with foreign powers to gain his
position in the white house
they struggled to accept the results of
of a democratic process four years ago
and donald trump is not going to
hesitate
to return the favor i think the other
difficult thing for the democrats is
just how wrong those polls were
joe biden has seriously underperformed
because the expectations were set
so high they thought this was going to
be a huge landslide but as it turns out
probably because the economy was so
strong before coronavirus hit
the president had a lot more support
than they expected and
one of the reasons i think this election
hasn't been called yet is because it
is possible that it comes down to a
handful of electoral votes
they're still outstanding states if they
all go to joe biden then you know this
will be a pretty resounding victory in
terms of the electoral college
for uh for joe biden but it just wasn't
what they were expecting as james says
there were there was no blue wave
and that would be very disappointing for
the democrats who didn't just want to
win they wanted to crush donald trump
i always wonder sometimes for the
democrats sound a little bit like the
burbons they seem to know nothing learn
nothing
and then forget nothing i remember
watching hillary clinton
in the final days of the campaign it had
dawned on her uh that she was in a bit
of trouble in pennsylvania so they
organized this huge
concert in philadelphia with beyonce and
it goes out on the network news
television and all the rest of it
but actually the reaction of people in
what is disparagingly called the flyover
states
is that we don't want to be lectured to
by a bunch of multi-millionaire
uh virtue signals so what does joe biden
do
he throws a concert in philadelphia with
lady gaga who does the same as beyonce i
mean don't they learn
uh it often appears that they don't i
think what would have been more
difficult for joe biden is that in that
second debate where
the former vice president was allowed to
speak more and
donald trump was forced to be a bit more
silent
he came out more or less against
fracking as something that has led to
u.s energy independence and created a
heck of a lot of
jobs in america now millions upon
millions of ballot
ballots will have already been cast by
the time we got to that second debate
but i have no doubt that it would have
sent
some voters back to donald trump james
the one thing that we cannot say uh
is that this election even if mr biden
is now the next president i think it
will make him the 46th president
of the united states even if that
happens strangely contrary to what
the opinion pulls to what 95 percent of
the american meat media
the pundit class contrary to what they
told us
this election was not a repudiation of
trumpism
no i think you i think it's quite clear
looking at these election results
that if it hadn't been for covid donald
trump would have won
and i think it is close enough that as
the republican pollster frank lancer
says
you you can believe that if donald trump
had turned in a slightly more restrained
and measured performance in that first
presidential debate
he the result might have been different
again i think this is
i think this shows you the deep well of
support that there is there how evenly
divided the us is between these two very
different ways of kind of thinking about
politics and i think the big question
now is you know
you can on the one hand you can say look
uh biden starts off in a weak position
with a republican senate
the big question is whether he can find
a way
to revive the kind of lost art of
washington deal making
whether he can find a way to advance his
agenda not get everything he wants but
get you know 60 70
of what he wants and present that as
victory and kind of end the kind of
partisan gridlock that has become such a
defining feature of u.s politics
in recent years before
uh the we can be sure of a biden
presidency of course not only have all
the votes got to be counted
but we've then got to deal with the
litigation that donald trump has been
promising
long before people even started voting
and it is clear that in those states
where it is possible to have a recount
mr trump will do so and the republican
establishment will go along with that
why wouldn't they
it may be clear whether some egregious
examples of voter fraud or of real
question marks over the mail-in ballots
or the in-person ballots
they could go along with that too
particularly in states where it's
close but will the republican leadership
indulge in
him week after week after week in trying
to stop this james
i don't think so i think you've seen the
way that mitch mcconnell the republican
senate majority leader has said look you
know
let's let's let the votes play out i i
think as you say
they're not going to stop donald trump
from going for recounts all this or that
but if he if he begins to move into a
territory it can affect spacious
lawsuits and it is worth remembering
that donald trump's answer to most
problems is to sue them you know he
famously uh
told theresa may that her approach to
the brexit negotiation should be to sue
the eu
um and you know he is a classic new york
real estate guy and
suing is what he does uh i think if he
starts to kind of
carry on like that i think you will see
republicans
put more distance between themselves and
him
uh because i think i think i think they
i think that because you know
you've got you've got a supreme court
now of a healthy conservative majority
on it the republicans have got control
of the senate they actually had
quite good results at the statewide
level in these elections
i don't mean they're going to go totally
down with the
trump ship now and i think i also think
back do you remember when
mitch mcconnell said after trump got
covered he said look i haven't been to
the white house for months because i
don't think it's a safe environment
i think there are issues on which even
mitch mcconnell is prepared
to put distance between himself and
donald trump
cain a win is a win is a win if mr biden
has got 270 or more electoral college
votes
that's a win he becomes the next
president
but i can't help feeling and i and it's
reinforced when i speak to democrats
that
they're relieved they've won because at
one stage of the night it looked like
they might not win
but they're hardly triumphant are they i
mean it was hardly a convincing victory
so far he was dragged over the winning
line if that's what's happened he's 78
he's a one-time president almost
certainly he'll be 82 by the
time of the next election and he hasn't
managed
to bring the senate with him and it's
just been
a struggle to win in some states and he
lost florida
the democrats yet again i mean it's
great to win
to be on the winning side but you you
you would have reservations about the
scale or nature of the victory would you
not
you should they shouldn't be too tough
with themselves i think it's safe to say
that their mandate is to not be donald
trump but it's hard to say
what else their mandate would be from
this kind of result the democrats were
really hopeful that they could pin
all of their woes on hillary clinton if
joe biden had a massive landslide then
the problem was her as a candidate and
the fact that she didn't campaign
in the right areas or send the right
messaging but now it's clear that
america is
very divided the democrats have not won
the battle of ideas they did not sway as
many
hearts and minds as they thought they
would now that being said i'm going to
slightly disagree with james that if it
had not been for
coven 19 donald trump would have stormed
into victory
i think the way that trump acted in that
first debate some pollsters suggest
really turned off suburban women and the
way that he acted the stunts that he
pulled
after kovid 19 and and his personal
dealing with that virus when he came
back to the white house
was acting triumphant uh was implying
that the virus was not a serious risk
that we had
cures for it which we do not uh you know
the the many americans that have been
affected by
now over 200 000 people in america dying
from this virus will not have responded
well to that um now i guess that
sentence don't wouldn't have happened if
it hadn't been for coven 19 but we can
be sure there would have been something
else i think it's still clear that
donald trump's behavior
turns off voters particularly women i
always thought joe biden had a decent
chance against donald trump but
what none of us knew was just how close
this would be so the democrats are going
to have to learn lessons as well
as the republicans but i would echo
james in saying that at least they now
have uh someone like joe biden who has a
reputation for extending his hand
working across the aisle quite famously
when he was vice president when barack
obama got fed up and couldn't speak to
the republicans anymore
over something like raising the debt
ceiling he'd send in joe biden
and joe would work it out and he is
respected by many republicans across the
aisle
so i think we can have little glimmers
of hope that joe biden and a republican
senate may be able to work together to
get some bipartisan legislation through
it does still feel very far away
not simply because joe biden isn't
inaugurated until january but
because we know that there are going to
be lawsuits donald trump has already
launched three
in georgia in michigan and pennsylvania
is really the one to watch
he has said he wants to take that to the
supreme court it's not simply about the
result but whether or not the state
itself should be counting certain votes
if they arrived past the election day
so there's a lot to play out before we
get to a point where we're talking about
president biden and the republican
senate working together
james if i was mitch mcconnell i'd be
thinking
i'm not going to go to the wire with
donald trump now it's clear that
the republicans have lost the white
house uh
i'm really quite glad to see the back of
him he was difficult to
get on with i'm still the senate
majority leader
the republicans still control the senate
which means
mr biden will be president biden will be
very cribbed and confined
we have essentially a republican
majority
on the supreme court too and hey i'm a
deal maker
i've done deals in the past with joe de
biden he's a constant
consumer washington swamp dealmaker so
we'll be fine
and every confirmation he wants to make
will have to be passed through me
as well so we'll get on fine with sleepy
joe he's a bit old i'm a bit old as well
mitch mcconnell it would be nice if the
republicans head on to the white house
but hey
we can live with the next four years and
start building a post-republican trump
party
yeah and i think the interesting
question will be what kind of republican
party they try to build
my hunch is that republicans in the
senate will just
rediscover fiscal conservatism now that
donald trump has gone
uh they'll be reluctant to sign off and
are too big of a stimulus package for
the economy
you know post covid economic recovery
plan
but i think the interesting question
there is when you look at these results
it's quite clear that there are the
potential gains for the republicans
are down the income scale you know that
they are
but they made gains with the working
class you know of of all ethnicities in
the us
and how do they try and build on that
and you know how do you attempt trumpism
about trump and i think it's gonna be an
interesting question here because you
know on the one hand
trumpism has really been about trump and
his personality
uh which as kate wright he said does
repels as many voters as
it attracts the question is can you find
a way
to build a republican assembly that is
kind of socially conservative that
economically prioritizes the
interests of uh on those on middle and
lower incomes which is which would be a
big deviation from kind of classic
republican economic orthodoxy
can you do that and i think one of the
other reasons why this is going to be so
interesting is
that as you said about joe biden's age i
i think we are looking at
both parties both the republicans and
democrats having primaries in 2024 to
pick
their candidate for president and i
think joe biden will try and use the
fact that he's likely to be a one-time
president to do the deals you know he'll
say look you know
you're not guaranteeing my re-election
by doing a deal with me mitch this is
you know i'll be gone but the question
is which philosophical route
do both parties decide to go down in
2024 because
i think if you look at these results you
know this is how a democrat the
democratic party has
just it looks like regained its blue
wall in the upper midwest
with a white irish catholic from
scranton pennsylvania
it it it suggests that the democrats
have a lot more work to do
if they are going to make that that that
blue that build that blue wall back up
to the kind of electoral advantage it
was for them until the 2016 cycle
you see can a lot of uh republicans or
sometimes what were called republicans
in name only the rhinos
thought if only we can get rid of donald
trump we can get our party back
um but that isn't going to be the way it
will work out because you get your party
back but then what do you make of it
because
if as james was saying the american
elections now are not
what are lost on the east coast they're
not one of the lost on the west coast
they are solidly democrat on both sides
they're not one or lost in the south
which is still
largely reliably uh republican
they're won or lost in the midwest in
these rust belt states the great lakes
stakes the one we've
talked about endlessly pennsylvania
michigan and all the rest of it
so you can hardly go back to a kind of
country club republicanism of the
rockefellers
and and thomas dewey and all the rest of
it
but nor can you go to oregonite
republicanism of the
west coast which was limited government
much lower
uh taxes the people in these midwest
states
they want sort of lunch pail politics
they want better medicare
they want better schools for their kids
they want more government spending so i
would suggest that
none neither of the two previous
republican traditions
of ike eisenhower or of ronald reagan i
mean losing arizona if that's what's
happened
couldn't be more totemic for them that
was the crucible
of western republicanism they need to
develop a new kind of republican
republicanism kate well i completely
agree andrew that the republican party
has made the mistake for decades now
being far too nostalgic about the 1980s
and
not thinking about the future and what
it means to adapt republican values and
ideas
to the world that we live in now not the
world that we lived and then i think
often forgetting that the
the tax breaks and the deregulation that
ronald reagan brought in
were quite extraordinary for the time
they were radical ideas and the
republican party needs
new radical ideas of its own i'm less
convinced however that all of this comes
down to state spending i think when
you're looking at those rust belt states
there's a
real sense of self-sufficiency in those
states i don't think everybody's
desperate for a handout i think they
want more efficiency
and i think they want decent policy what
we haven't spoken about yet but we
cannot overlook
were those tax breaks that the
republican party brought in in 2017.
that was the first time in a long time i
think that gdp
wasn't just a you know facts and figures
on a spreadsheet anymore that people
actually understood what it meant to be
more prosperous they saw the results in
that
of higher wages bonuses from their
countries that were directly
directly pegged to those tax breaks and
in that sense that's a you know very
traditional uh republican
kind of policy on the other side the
trade wars are thought to have dampered
the u.s economy it could have thrived
even more had donald trump not engaged
in a narrative that's thought to appeal
to areas like that but in practice
hasn't been as successful and if we look
at those exit polls andrew
the economy so far anyway from the exit
polls that we've seen in the data we
have
ranks at the top of people's list for
the issue that they cared about most and
one exit poll
coronavirus um was was half that
people really cared about getting the
economy back on track
and i think if republicans can stick to
that messaging with some innovative
kinds of public policy and if they can
make the cells on healthcare and
education that they want to empower the
individual
say through school choice and vouchers
which the president was starting to do
but didn't make
uh great inroads on i think there is a a
new future for the republican party that
doesn't have to abandon everything that
they've stood for
but just recognizes that in 2020 it
might have to look slightly different
and we
you know you you might have to work a
little bit harder on the details of the
policy to make sure it works for the
nation now
james a biden presidency if that's what
it is
then we'll finish on this before we move
on
every major confirmation will have to be
our nomination will have to be run
through the
republican senate
he will have to deal with a republican
in essence
supreme court uh
he will be in a rush to get some things
done because he's probably just a one
term president he wants a major stimulus
packet with
a big green new deal so-called
spending tagged onto it he'll need mitch
mcconnell to approve that
as well i it's not surprising that wall
street
seems to rather have like the idea of a
biden presidency
uh the left of the democrats for now has
been cribbed and confined
and but there will be a stimulus package
but it won't
be out of the ballpark stimulus package
it'll be controlled
so he will be a moderate president
yeah i think joe i think joe biden's
personal politics
are moderate it's worth remembering that
he was a dlc democrat back in the late
80s the democratic leadership council
the group from which the new democrats
and bill clinton
came out of you know the dings on him in
the democratic primary all came from the
left that you know he sponsored crime
bills or welfare bills
that that were emblematic of that new
approach so i think you will see him
very much
govern in in that manner and i think i
think what we will see
is i suspect in 2024 if joe biden
doesn't run i suspect we will see a
uh primary challenge to kamala harris in
that race
as they think the left of a democratic
party say you're not doing enough you're
not delivering enough already
alexander aoc that the new york
congresswoman
stand the bearer of democratic left has
been saying look the reason the
republicans
the democrats didn't get as big a margin
with hispanic voters as they were hoping
for
was they they weren't left-wing enough
they didn't do enough to infuse them
and i think you will see a big argument
coming in both parties about
which philosophical direction they
should go in and i think there'll be
i think there'll be lots of early
grouching about you know what is joe
biden delivering for the left
i think that's right and the the it must
have dawned on the
both parties by now that in the 21st
century
elections are won or lost in the rust
belt and the great lakes
states and you need to pick a candidate
that can win these states because that's
how you
win the election now and i think that's
a big problem for kavala harris
uh a west coast uh lawyer uh
because you've got the democrats have
got the west coast and her appeal is
very limited in these other states and
it means as the republicans move away
from trump
they can't entirely move away for those
elements of
trumpism that appeal to the blue collar
workers
the rural and the small town workers in
these states so there's going to be a
fascinating battle as a biden presidency
settles in
for the soul of both the republican and
the democrat
uh parties and of course we'll be across
all of that at the spectator
as the months and years ahead now today
back here in dear old blighty england
goes back
into lockdown comes after a febrile
weekend of politics in westminster
one of the most confusing probably one
of the most badly handled announcements
in the modern history of announcements
but that's process that's politics which
are a problem
for boris johnson why have we gone back
into a lockdown what are the numbers
that justify
england going back in to the full monty
or nearly the full monty
locked down as always fraser can tell us
that he's got charts to show what he
means fraser over to you
thanks andrew well this is the big
question that politicians were asking
this week only a couple of weeks ago
and boris johnson was saying no we're
not going to do another lockdown that
would be disaster over the country the
mental health the economic damage would
be
unthinkable so we're going to continue a
policy of local
and regional action then he abandoned
this
why the answer we were told lie in the
data
but what we saw on saturday last weekend
it was a debacle
the like of which we haven't seen for a
long time and hopefully won't see
again the first graph we saw came not
from the prime minister
but from a leak to the the bbc on lauren
koonsburg the political editor twitter
feed
she came out with the graph purporting
to show up to 4 000
daily deaths from the second wave of
kovid
now given that there were only a
thousand deaths in the peak of the first
wave that's looking at a second wave
not just bigger than the first but
potentially four times bigger
now at the time it was said now surely
she's got hold of a rogue
graph that can't it can't really be as
bad as that but when the actual press
conference came along
then yes that graph came back and we saw
yet again
up to 4 000 deaths that's one of the
scenarios and there were four other
scenarios
all of which showing daily deaths
peaking significantly higher
than the thousand a day that we saw in
the first
wave now we've actually got a hold of
these figures at the spectator because
at the time it wasn't clear what the
figures were
it wasn't clear what the assumptions
were it wasn't even clear
who had made the assumptions the
projections had been released
without any context without any labels
all the public saw and we're talking 15
million people waiting to watch strictly
come dancing you couldn't get a bigger
government an audience for a government
announcement than that
all they were told the takeaway was of
all these scary graphs up to 4 000
dead well so far and we're now tracking
it on the spectator you can see the
actual figure
at the bottom and the actual deaths are
still running around
230 240 a day
um and you can also see that by now even
at this stage
one of the scenarios shown on saturday
has britain at about a thousand
deaths so already by the time it was
shown to the public it was way
out of date and way higher than it
needed to be now this isn't the first
time we've been showing
um scary scenarios at number 10 it
wasn't so long ago that sir patrick
valance the chief scientific officer
came up with a graph showing what it
would be like if cases were to double
every seven days
the graph showed up to 50 000 confirmed
coveted cases a day
by the middle of october at the time he
said this was a
projection not a forecast but you can be
um if you're watching at home you could
be forgiven for not quite
understanding the distinction between
these two it was the only graph that he
showed
and as we can see here the actual number
came in at less than half that
that was for the middle of october even
now we're running at about
25 000 cases a day you can see the um
the daily uh the daily readings in pink
and the seven day moving average is a
red line
what that shows is there isn't much of
an increase this sudden surge
that we were told about in the press
conference just isn't coming through in
the daily data on the contrary
it seems that things are flattening now
you might say okay
maybe the young people have stopped
getting coronavirus but the older the
over 60s that's what matters
that's true but let's have a look then
at the virus amongst the over 60s
we see even these levels are starting to
flatten now in many regions of the uk
in other words it looks as if the
government's regional and local strategy
might have been working
this was a point theresa may made when
she gave her a presentation to the house
of commons
she was saying look why has the
government given up when it seems
that we haven't had a proper analysis of
the impact of a strategy we've just
abandoned the evidence from liverpool
she says shows up a number of cases is
falling
she wanted a proper assessment of the
regional policy before
moving to national lockdown we'd seen
lots of figures
chunted out without much explanation of
what they meant
and if you have a look at the liverpool
figures theresa may's referring to
we can see now that the number of cases
a day in liverpool
are almost half of what they were in the
peak
of last month now this is not a picture
of a virus running out of control in
liverpool
and it's in liverpool where the
government's next big experiment
will start we're going to see a mass
testing in liverpool everyone in the
city is being offered a covert test
whether they
um are sick or not and the government
sees this a prototype of rolling it out
for the whole country potentially 10
million
tests a day we're told and that might be
our get out of jail free card or at
least our get out of lockdown card
but then this raises so many questions
about data
if you're doing 10 million tests a day
what proportion of those will be false
positive
if you test false positive will you be
isolated on a false premise
and will we be once again lost in a fog
of data
it seems right now as if we got into
lockdown based not on what's actually
happening in the ground but on some
models suggesting what might be
happening
visa models which only today the uk
statistics authority has taken the very
unusual step
of reprimanding the government for its
use of data it says in its words
there is the potential to confuse the
public and to undermine
and confidence in statistics if you use
scary charts
in this way so it's really unusual now
to have lockdown you couldn't get a
bigger measure than this
justified on the basis of statistics
which even
the uk statistics authority said were
misrepresented when presented to the
public
on saturday back over to you andrew
fraser uh thank you for that and showing
the the church
charts i'm delighted to say we're joined
by one of the country's leading
statisticians
professor david spiegel-halter winton
professor of public understanding of
risk at the university of cambridge
formerly president of the royal
statistics society
a professor welcome to spectator tv uh
i'd like to speak a general point to you
and then
then you discuss you can discuss with
fraser some more of the details but a
lot of people are beginning to think
that the the senior scientists
and the politicians from mr johnson down
have been complicit in concocting
scary scenarios with statistics that are
never properly inter
interrogated to to kind of scare us into
compliance with whatever policy
it is they want us to follow so we had
the
50 000 cases which was merely an
arithmetic
uh projection uh by the middle of
october
and then we've had this more complicated
chart with 4 000
deaths if we don't do anything
we're beginning to wonder if this isn't
the kind of propaganda dictators
used to keep their populations in place
what do you say to that okay this is
quite a difficult issue first of all
i've got to admit a conflict of interest
possibly that i am on the non-executive
director on the board of the uk stats
authority
that oversees the office for statistical
regulation
that just has has made that announcement
that fraser referred to
and um but i'm speaking completely
personally at this stage and i have to
say yeah
i'm really not at all keen on the sort
of graphs that
fraser has been showing and and that's
why i fully support the statements
that's been made by the osr and i think
it's really unfortunate because i also
personally believe
that those that sort of model this 4 000
peak which i'd like to come back to a
bit more in a moment
um it was actually unnecessary in order
to make the argument i
where i i fraser's analysis was very
reasonable when it concerned
those speculative graphs being used
and you know in a very way to i think
influence people's emotions
but i don't think he's correct when he
says that the data itself
does not justify measures now i'm not
going to say
i'm not going to say i support the
lockdown i'm not going to say i support
anything that's not my job
is i'm a statistician and um you know i
i look at the data but only the data
concerning covet
and of course anybody anybody making a
decision about lockdown where we know
it has ramifications way beyond just
covet impact in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths
obviously has to take that broader
picture into account which i cannot do
but i do believe that just looking at
the data
alone and chris witte this is what he
said the next day where he
said oh i don't use those projections i
just look a few weeks ahead
um to the um science and technology
committee
for parliament if you just look at the
current trends
we are um you know in a very difficult
position by the end of this month
now i i admit actually i not admit i
mean i'm
in a way pleased that cases have largely
plateaued
the picture that's shown in tier
liverpool and other tier three cases i
think it has worked you know these cases
have reduced
however in other parts of the country
which the graph showed
they're going up um and in in actually
the lower risk areas the west country
the south east east except in the
midlands
they they're steadily going up so this
plateau is made up of two conflicting
trends
um but the other thing is this plateau
which is 20 to 25
000 cases a day is absolutely certain
to lead to consequences over the next
four weeks
um roughly speaking two to two and a
half thousand hospitalizations per day
in two weeks and maybe a week after that
500 deaths a day and there's nothing we
can do about that now no measure
would do anything would change that
we're that's in the die
of the number of people who are
currently infected now
even if you think that the tier system
is working
i mean i'm just guessing at the sort of
discussions that must have been going on
last week
where it's clear the tier system you
know i think is working to some extent
r has been coming down we're moving
towards and are perhaps of one
but all that does is stabilize the
situation at twenty to twenty five
thousand positive cases a day
and what i'm what the date that's pure
just looking at the data
and that would not be sustainable you
can do it as a peak
but two and a half thousand um
hospitalizations per day
500 deaths a day carrying over week
after week is simply not sustainable
um in the nhs because we have to keep
the nhs open for everybody else that was
the mistake made in the previous wave
that everyone's very keen to avoid again
we're not
the nhs must be open for business for
everybody else
covid absolutely right you should not
trump the
uh you know the general um illness and
health of
of the nation fraser
what i'm interested to know david is
what you
what we've seen in the figures in the
last week or two weeks to change the
government's policies erratically i mean
a couple of weeks ago
boris johnson was had to set his face
set against um
lockdown set his face against circuit
breakers
and then all of a sudden we were given
these figures on saturday night to
suggest why the situation
had changed now i couldn't see much in
these figures that was a material change
the situation we thought we were dealing
with
a week ago and and when you look and
also i'd be interested to know
um where you think it's approp whether
you think it's appropriate
to show modeling of that nature to a
prime time
saturday audience it seems to me to be a
rather
strange way to use m statistics i may
have a
contradictory effect of making people
far less willing to believe what the
government says
if they think the government is
exaggerating the case i mean
whether i'm you're doing this i'm
talking about a pandemic or simply
making a presentation to your company
you surely ought to be coming up with
figures which are regarded
as realistic so people think you're not
in the business of trying to scare
anybody with
um with figures whose assumptions you
don't disclose
i absolutely agree and and i said that i
i don't think the use of that graph was
was um inappropriate would be an
understatement
i think in a potentially extreme as it
has been
extremely damaging for what i think is a
reasonable case
that something um serious must be done
extra interventions must be done which i
do believe
so get back to that graph first of all i
really must ask you don't keep on
dragging it out i mean i know you can
drag it out and say oh well this shows
this isn't the whole
this isn't happening but it's unfair to
the scientists
that was produced as uh you know clearly
it wasn't part of any official document
at all
it was produced at the beginning of
october under different assumptions
the the cambridge model that goes up to
four thousand a day they'd already
changed twice
and reduced dramatically by last week by
the middle of last week
and so it was it was out of date it was
never meant
for because it you know and it was never
in a document that was going to be later
released
it was somehow leaked we won't go into
that i
don't know why that happened and then it
appeared and and
you know i actually it's bad enough that
it appeared on saturday and then to
introduce that you
put it in again in the papers for
parliament
for the wait for the debate yesterday i
really think no
that's just not on you know really and
it so damages the case and increases as
you said
the possibility of people mistrusting
feel that they're being
influenced and manipulated by the data
when
i why i get really upset about this as
you can tell as a statistician
that i feel the data the trends going on
the data are serious enough
on their own they didn't need to use
this graph this is a powerful
what is going on is powerful you you ask
well what
changed i think again i'm purely
guessing here
maybe they thought that the tier system
was going to be more effective
in bringing r down below you know down
to one even below
and what they found is that it was
bringing down infections in these severe
areas like liverpool it has worked there
but
elsewhere in the country it is going up
really quite dramatically the fastest
increases are in the southwest
you know people are getting i'm from
devon you know and i my family's old
people are getting it for the first time
they didn't get it in the first wave
they're now getting it so you could see
that something
big was needed because otherwise we
would be in for an unsustainable winter
even if
the um the infection stays at a steady
level that is not
a sustain a sustainable level for them
to stay at
frieza what's the answer to that well
it's interesting that i wonder to whom
we turn now for figures to find out
what's going on
and if not the government i completely
take what david says that these
figures the government showed us were
never intended by those who drew them
to be presented to an audience of 15
million people
it makes it harder than ever right to to
get the signal from the noise to look at
every day
we at the spectator have started a new
data hub data.spectator.cod.uk
updating every single day the various
figures so people can try to work out
what's happening i guess the question is
where are we heading to
in two or three weeks time um and there
doesn't seem to be
an office for budget responsibility a
neutral body here
that you can you can look at to get a a
balanced view
and and that which in this current
pandemic this is a little bit worrying
um but the other thing i'm really
interested to know david's opinions on
is what you think about mass testing
we're going to start in liverpool
we're going to get you know to test
everybody in the city that's quite an
undertaking it has been
we've seen this happen in in chinese
cities we've seen this happen in
slovenia in some places
but if we do end up in a situation where
you're testing the whole population of a
city even a country
at 10 million people a day what are the
potential there
for false positives and for data to give
a potentially misleading picture
okay great questions the first one first
a wonderful spectate what the
spectator is doing on there david this
is great stuff so all i can do is
recommend
do just do a three week projection you
don't need any fancy models for that i
mean my rule of thumb as i've mentioned
before you just take the number of
positive cases each day divided by 10
and that's the number of
hospitalizations in two weeks divided by
50 that's the number of deaths in three
to four weeks
so you know it's that simple and yeah
and it's not bad it's not bad at all
and then you and that's nothing to do
with models and it's nothing to do
actually with any policies we're stuck
with it
so i think you know just do a short-term
projection and you'll realize
whoa this is um you know this is not
sustainable
okay mass testing very important indeed
um and you know and it's to do with the
false positives is the crucial thing
you know if you're testing you know
people were you
kind of think that a one percent false
positive right sounds great 99 accurate
no it's useless for a test because if
you test a million people in a day one
is 10 000 people falsely being told
they've got coveted and having to
isolate and that sort of thing and that
would be unacceptable
so there's two things to say first of
all for a decent test like a current pcr
test
the false positive rate is not one
percent one in a hundred it's much less
than one in two thousand it's actually
very small indeed and so there's been a
whole lot of misinformation about how
most of the tests being done a false
positive this is a complete nonsense and
utter misinformation
so don't believe any of that stuff so
the pcr test is actually
pretty good even for mass testing
um when the prevalence is low and that
means the false the
it becomes less reliable but we're not
going to be doing pcr tests for this for
this mass testing we're going to be
doing much shorter briefer tests that
have been done
if their you know false positive rate is
as low as that
then actually it won't be too big you
know it's manageable
if it isn't they're going to have to um
do a repeat test to make it so
essentially if you've got a false
positive rate if it were one percent
which is far too high on its own for
mass testing
but then if you do it again either with
it the same or with a more another pcr
test
then again you hugely reduce the false
positive rate so
i think that you need it's not just a
matter of testing everybody if you're
positive you go to isolators and i don't
think that would be
unless it's a really accurate test it's
not a feasible strategy for mass
testing but actually a two-stage
strategy where people who test positive
then after test again two days later
seems completely
um achieve it does seem achievable and
in the end i think it's going to be the
only way
to get things going again but we don't
yet know i don't think the quality
of these tests we're buying millions of
these things but
um i would like to have a lot more
evidence on what their actual false
positive rate is and their
and their false negative rate i mean how
many people are they picking up
professor speaker halter we're going to
have to leave it there but
thank you for your contribution today i
hope you come back on spectator tv
as events develop and we can discuss
more of these issues with you it's been
a pleasure to listen to
uh what you had to say today and to help
us understand more
what is happening that was david
spiegel-halter of the university of
cambridge i just want to touch briefly
on the politics of this
with james and kate before we then move
on to our final item today which is
turkey
james speaking in the past week or so to
tori's
i've been struck by just how
hostile backbenchers donors
uh the tory faithful how hostile they
are now about boris johnson
they almost don't really like him
anymore
i mean there's a huge opposition to
lockdown you saw
first-year tory mps rebelling last night
on the second lockdown
i mean the big question which downing
street has got to come up and answer
is this is the tactical lockdown about
first david spiegel was saying about
hospital capacity
what is your strategy for avoiding
another one because it is worth
remembering that when sage
the scientific advisors initially
suggested this kind of circuit breaker
style lockdown
they admitted that you would probably
need another one of these later in the
winter
and i think if you came back to the
house of commons in january or february
saying
right we now want you to vote for a
third lockdown
i think you would see a really big tory
rebellion then
and i think you would be in a position
where boris johnson was having to rely
on
labor votes to get the policy through
and that never ends well for any prime
minister when you have to start relying
on opposition votes
to get your business through the house
of commons kate it's quite hard to
remind ourselves that less than a year
ago boris johnson took the tories to
their biggest victory
uh since maggie thatcher landslide
against neil kinnick in 1987
and he would see he won all these old
labor seats in the north he was the
savior
of the tory party he was the new tory
party of the north as well as
the south labor was in a mess
i mean the transformation the decline in
his
status in the eyes of tories in 11
months
is quite breathtaking
i think the fall from grace has happened
much more recently
actually you don't have to go back to
december and and watch the timeline from
there if we
go back to march and april the nation
really rallied behind the prime minister
they understood that the nation it
turned out wasn't properly prepared when
this pandemic hit
he himself suffered from the virus so
from mps to your average joe on the
street i think the prime minister was
really supported in the actions that he
took
even when he had to lock the country
down the problem came this summer
and it's become very clear now that the
right things were not done to build up
capacity
in the nhs billions of pounds instead
were put behind
a test trace and isolate scheme which
hasn't worked it's been woeful it's
experienced
u-turns there's been so many problems
with it and unfortunately we now
find england back in lockdown we have
circuit breakers we have firebreakers
and many people are now asking you know
what did you do
this i think is where the fall from
grace really has
begun it's going to be a difficult
winter season for boris johnson as he
probably faces more rumbles and
slightly increasing opposition to the
measures that he's taking but i think
the real breaking point
comes next spring the chancellor today
announced that he is extending the
furlough scheme until march 2021
that means that essentially for a year
some people will be sitting at home
having the government paying their wages
and when we talk about these policies
trickling into the new year i think
that's when people get
deeply frustrated whether they're in
parliament business owners employees
everybody starts to think wait a second
this can't go on for another year this
cannot define 2021
in the way that it's defined this year
so i suspect that's when things get
really difficult for the prime minister
now perhaps the breaking point coincides
with mass testing
perhaps it coincides with a vaccine but
if it doesn't and we have to learn how
to live with this virus and no mechanism
is in place
i think that's when you can see the
conservative party take a real change
in their attitude towards the prime
minister well thank you for that kate
now while
most of western europe has been having
to come to terms with
uh the prospect of new lockdowns almost
as tough
as the lockdowns of march and april uh
it has also had to contend with a new
wave of terrorism
not a terrorism on a spectacular scale
killing tens and tens and tens or even
hundreds of people
but individual lone wolfs uh causing
mayhem and nice
uh in avignon uh and then the latest of
all in
vienna and it coincides with a
a spat more than a spat between france
and turkey uh where relations are
probably at a modern
law and part of the battle of
islamism as president macron sees it has
been to bring him into contention
with turkey at the same time the history
of the
21st century which is only two decades
old which was
supposed to be and to see the final
success confirmation of democracy after
the fall of the berlin wall in 89
and more latin american countries
becoming democratic as well
instead of seeing that final triumph of
democracy what
the history of the 20th century 21st
century so far has been
has been the rise of authoritarianism
and the rise of the strong strongman
authoritarians becoming totalitarians
like the
chinese communist party with president
xi
russia going back into authoritarianism
with president putin erdogan
president in turkey again a strong man
and increasingly authoritarian same in
brazil
consolidation of power around the crowd
prince in saudi arabia
and of course this little rocket man in
north korea is still with us as well so
you see a trend there and
i just like to to work out in the case
of turkey
which is uh so close to europe and for
many years we had thought
was becoming part of the european way
of doing things now seems to be going in
a different direction is it partner of a
clash of civilizations
is it part of this growth of strongman
leaders
is it part of this growing
authoritarianism i'm delighted to say
we're joined by edgar
temel kuran uh an award-winning
turkish journalist author of how to lose
a country the seven steps from democracy
uh to dictatorship uh
edgar is it right now to regard
president erdogan in turkey as an
authoritarian
definitely definitely absolutely
can you explain to us how this has come
about in turkey because for
for a huge part of the 20th century we
looked at turkey
as good way back to ataturk and so on as
becoming more of a
much more of a secular state of a
separation of which in western you you
would have a
call a separation of church and state
the modernization of turkey the
the europe uh looking way for turkey
even hoping at one stage
for membership of the european union it
was definitely a democracy
flawed in places but all democracies
have their flaws away
as we see across the atlantic at the
moment
what has brought this uh about which
many people will regard as a reversal
why uh well there is this dominant
narrative
both in turkey and outside turkey about
the country that
turkey was a secular country until recep
tayyip erdogan
decided to take it you know towards a
different direction
whereas i see it
from where i see it it all goes back to
1980 military coup
before that uh secularism was
not completely healthy and uh
fortified maybe but after 1980 military
coup
um the top generals of the army
cooperated with religious sects
one of them being fethullah moment later
that became very important not only in
turkish politics but
in international politics as well so
and at the time as you know there was
the cold war and
not only in turkey but also in
afghanistan in several other places
radical islam or political islam for
that matter
was utilized by
nato against ussr farmers ussr
so these guys were like sort of
recruited
by an ideology to have to
struggle against uh communism the danger
of communism
and then when their job was over after
the berlin wall
when it came down uh they have to they
they could they were like sort of uh
jobless so after 1990s was
quite important in that sense because
that was the time
uh political islam
became more mainstream
so to speak and then 2000 when 2000s
arrived when especially after 9 11
there was another ideological project if
you will which is called moderate islam
and turkey became
the role model for moderate islam
moderate
and the idea was democracy can go
together
hand in hand with moderate islam and
turkey can be
the example country for the rest of the
muslim world
to show that democracy can flourish
in muslim countries so i don't know if
you remember obama was
praising mr erdogan alongside with
several other western leaders
he was one of the five most trusted
international leaders mr obama told us
yeah and it's only 10 years ago
and after i think after 2007
when mr erdogan came to power for the
second time
things got a little bit troublesome and
after 2013 after the gizzy uprising
when the entire world so that the things
are not
what they want to see in turkey
then on things started getting down the
hill
but now of course the all these
supporting masses of mr erdogan has been
mobilized
and organized and mobilized around the
you know
around religion so you cannot
just stop it all of a sudden when
it becomes you know uh problematic
can i ask you what is in your view what
is
president erdogan's strategic goal for
turkey
what does he want it to be in the decade
that is now
ahead of us how does he want to position
turkey
in the region and the wider world
well this is an interesting question
because
one wants to believe that there is a
plan there
but for such leaders like mr erdogan or
putin or
several others now emerging everywhere
in europe
and like trump i do not think that they
have a plan
or an ideology or a perspective what
they want is power
and then more power end of story so
whatever fits their uh political agenda
or
desire for power they go that way
because mr erdogan
uh was quite enthusiastic about
europe and being in being in good
relations with
western countries during his first term
because then that was the necessary move
for him to stay in power but then it
became
insignificant for him so
if i can say that to be in good
relations with europe
uh because there were you know there was
trump there was putin
and to be in the to keep himself
in the game uh the only thing he could
he should have done was to keep his
relations good with these
two superpowers of the world but where
does he think he's going now is what i'm
trying
to to find out well um
turkey's relation to west uh
has been always problematic uh you know
west
has been this higher moral ground in
terms of democracy human rights and so
on
since western countries especially
european countries lost their last
residue of
uh moral superiority so to speak during
during the war in syria and during the
refugee crisis it is so easy for erdogan
to
um to have
a you know
to feel superior in that sense
um but i do not think that
he has a plan it changes every day so
i don't see a consistent plan
or uh project there well let me ask you
just one final question that if there's
not a plan
is there though a tactic is it
likely that turkey under mr erdogan will
now become
more repressive more authoritarian
i mean as i understand it the the media
is pretty much under his control
most of it that is a play a country
where you have to be careful what you
say
that there is a prevalent secret police
presence and so on
it has elements of authoritarianism is
that likely
sadly to get worse before it ever gets
better
absolutely because right now
economic power the entire political
machine
is under his control and what he's
trying to do
now is erase
the idea of rule of law from turkey
after the coup a coup attempt in 2016
um there as far as i know
4 000 judges were dismissed
suddenly in like in a very short period
of time they were replaced with
loyal judges and lately we have seen
meddling with a constitutional court as
well
so if he gets that one
that part of the machine that part of
the state
under his control i think there won't be
anything else to
unleash his desire for ultimate power
all right edge table kuran the author of
how to lose a country the seven steps
from democracy to dictatorship
award-winning
turkish journalist thank you for joining
us on spectator tv
that's just about it for this week
thanks to our guests once again to our
very special sponsor
charles stanley charles stanley one of
the oldest uk
leading wealth management firms also one
of the oldest firms on the london stock
exchange
remember if you subscribe to the
spectator this week to our u.s election
uh sale if you take part in this u.s
election sale you'll get 10 weeks of the
magazine
print and online 10 weeks all the way up
to christmas uh and beyond
for the price of one ten for the price
of one not only that
you get a commemorative spectator mug as
well to drink your coffee or tea
or the brandy you slip into it go to
spectator dot co dot uk
president to subscribe now send any
thoughts to spectator
tv at spectator dot co dot uk
join us again next thursday for another
the week
in 60 minutes bye bye
[Music]
you